this actually is kind of scary hey
everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen
[Music]
video is sponsored by better help and we
are back with another toxic episode
looking at the oh so controversial
ingredients in your food but first let
me tell you about my sponsor a better
help so as you guys know i've struggled
with anxiety my whole life and we know
how important mental health is for
healing our relationship with food and
body so in 2022 i'm really committing to
my mental health and working with a
registered therapist
is key to supporting my goals so i
recently discovered a better help which
is the world's largest online therapist
network with over 20 000 licensed
professional therapists it's not a
crisis line or a self-help line it's
professional therapy done securely
anywhere anytime online now the way it
works is that you just log into your
account anytime and send a message to
your therapist and you can get a timely
response without needing to wait weeks
between appointments and i know how
important this is because obviously we
can't always plan out our anxious
episodes so i know how nice it is to get
help when you really really need it it's
also a lot more affordable than
traditional in-person therapy and
there's also financial aid available for
those in need so if you're struggling
with your mental health check out
betterhelp.com
abby sharp to get 10 off of your first
month of therapy that's better h-e-l-p
and you can join over one million people
taking charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional all right let's get back to
those scary ingredients also a quick
disclaimer that you can see on screen or
in the description and reminder that if
you are new here hit that subscribe
button ring that bell and follow me over
on tick tock and instagram for more
great myth busting content all right so
if you missed my previous episode of the
series you can check that out right here
but to refresh i'm gonna be looking at
another round of scary food additives
and ingredients that so many wellness
experts insist you avoid and while i
totally understand that nutrition
information is overwhelming and that
reading food labels can be definitely
quite scary and intimidating here at
abby's kitchen we are all about food
facts not fear so let's kick things off
with nitrates now you may know nitrates
as the big bad curing agent that gets
added to processed foods like bacon
lunch meats salami and hot dogs and
they're used largely to help prolong
shelf life enhance color and flavor and
to prevent bacterial growth now
rightfully so there is some concern with
over consumption of nitrates from ultra
processed meats as research has linked
excessive intake to increased cancer
risk but like most things in nutrition
science it's not so cut and dry so some
research has found no association and
other studies suggest that it might just
be associated with some cancers but not
others ultimately though nobody wants
cancer so i fully understand the fear
that you may feel when an influencer
tells you that eating something is going
to harm you or of course harm your kids
but as we always say here the dose makes
the poison so it's not as if you have a
rash or a bacon and the next day you're
gonna fall ill in fact based on the best
evidence we have to date the world
health organization has set the
acceptable daily intake for nitrates at
3.7 milligrams per kilogram of body
weight per day which translates to
around 222 milligrams of nitrates for a
130 pound adult so to give you an idea
one slice of bacon roughly contains
.034 milligrams of nitrates and one
slice of deli meat contains
0.125 milligrams so this sounds
relatively insignificant right now it's
important to note that the limit set by
the who also factors in a dietary
nitrates we get from vegetables or even
our water supply which makes up for
around 80 percent of our dietary nitrate
intake i'll speak to why you don't need
to be concerned about nitrates and
veggies in just a hot minute but
hopefully that illustrates how
insignificant an occasional smoked meat
sandwich in your diet likely is
sometimes twice a day regardless of
course in response to public concern
over nitrates causing cancer food
manufacturers have found ways to market
their ultra processed meats as
nitrate-free so instead of using
synthetic nitrates they can use
naturally occurring nitrates from
vegetable sources like refined celery
powder and while there is no research to
date comparing the effects of natural
versus synthetic nitrates in the body
most experts suspect that the health
risks in a processed food like a hot dog
would be virtually the same because the
body sees naturally sourced and
synthetically sourced nitrates exactly
the same as for naturally occurring
nitrates in whole vegetables now it's
believed that the phytonutrient
compounds in vegetables like
antioxidants would likely buffer any
potential carcinogenic effects from the
nitrates explaining why a diet rich in
vegetables is consistently linked to a
reduced cancer risk in the research but
if we go back to the refined nitrates
found in ultra processed meats for a
second there may even be a potential
benefit from choosing a synthetic
nitrate over a health washed natural
version and that is that synthetic
nitrates are highly regulated and kept
so there's an upper limit to how much
can be used in any particular food while
naturally occurring nitrates like celery
powder are not so what that means is
that your nitrate-free bacon may
potentially have more nitrates than the
regular bacon while it's being passed
off by good marketing as nitrate-free so
my hot take on all of this is to aim to
enjoy processed meats and unprocessed
red meat in moderation regardless of
whether they're made with synthetic or
natural nitrates by focusing on diet
variety we can reduce the risk of over
consumption of any one additive like
nitrates and assuming you're enjoying a
wide range of colorful fruits and
veggies and a variety of plant-based
proteins as well i see no harm in an
occasional hot dog or deli sandwich hot
dogs get your hot dogs here
okay now let's move on to another biggie
gmos i'm gonna need some vodka in this
so in short gmos aka genetically
modified organisms are any living
organism that has had its dna modified
using genetic engineering technology to
help improve growth and nutritional
content while also enhancing resistance
to pesticides diseases and droughts in
fact an analysis of 147 studies found
that gmo technology has helped to reduce
chemical pesticide use by 37
and increased crop yields by 22
this not only makes farming much easier
but it also lowers costs for both
farmers and consumers in other words
gmos can potentially facilitate a
greater crop yield which allows farmers
to feed more people for less money they
can even be life-saving for some
communities so for example in a process
called bio-fortification gmo technology
has been used to add more vitamin a to
rice for populations with chronic
vitamin a deficiency otherwise known as
golden rice easier farming lower cost
greater yields and more nutrition sounds
like a no-brainer right well that is
until the gmo controversy comes into
play so initial concerns around gmos
were sparked when a study from the 90s
found that adding a protein from brazil
nuts into genetically modified soybeans
could potentially trigger an allergic
reaction for those allergic to brazil
nuts and while this gmo project was
quickly abandoned for this very serious
reason it led people to be suspicious of
foreign genes in our food thankfully
since this report there have been no
documented allergic reactions to any gmo
foods that currently exist on the market
gmo foods are also put through rigorous
testing to prevent any allergen transfer
from one food to another and research
has found that allergic reactions aren't
greater for a gmo food compared to a
non-gmo food so if you have a soy
allergy for example and you consume soy
from a gmo food or from a non-gmo food
the allergic reaction potential would be
the same now allergies aside the
wellness community is consistently
distrustful of gmos and largely plays
into what we call the natural fallacy so
this is a cognitive bias or assumption
that anything found in nature is good
and anything that's man-made is bad now
we've all seen scary instagram or blog
posts linking gmos to things like
infertility cancer liver toxicity and
antibiotic resistance in most cases this
is very much not evidence-based and when
there is research cited it's in animal
models none of these concerns have been
replicated in any quality evidence on
humans thus far and there's a lot of
research done on gmos lots and lots and
lots and lots now in the case of the
concern around the herbicide glyphosate
which is used in some gmo foods
glyphosate is classified as a possible
carcinogen which again sounds scary as
but when you do the digging you see that
it's classified as group 2a which
basically means it's based on limited
evidence of carcinogenicity
in humans and sufficient evidence in
animals with limited as being defined as
due to chance bias or other confounders
they also admit that the suggesting
evidence was based on agricultural
exposure to glyphosate not actual
ingestion of the stuff and as you can
imagine you get a much greater exposure
when you're literally working with a
chemical all day so in response a
systematic review and meta-analysis dove
deeper into the research to date and
found no causal relationship between
glyphosate and cancer there's also data
demonstrating that the trace amounts
found in some foods both gmos and also
non-gmo organics which are subject to
herbicide contamination are well below
residue limit standards now i have to
admit this is a huge topic and i would
need like a whole youtube series to
really unpack gmos and organics in
detail if we want to discuss all the
pros and cons at play which i am not
doing in this video here but the bottom
line here is that the safety of gmos is
well substantiated by the research which
is why major food authorities like the
fda epa and usda all deem gmos safe for
consumption now research has also
consistently shown no nutritional
difference between any given gmo and
non-gmo food and like we said in some
cases it can actually be modified to
have even more nutrition for vulnerable
populations but of course because the
term gmo conjures up images of like
aliens and frankenstein science
experiments
[Music]
the food industry is eager to distance
themselves from it whenever they can so
we often see the non-gmo label thrown
onto products that wouldn't ever contain
gmos in the first place so in the states
for example there are only 10 crops
approved to be genetically modified
including big cash crops like corn and
soybean but also a few other nutritious
staples like potatoes apples and summer
squash if you're seeing the non-gmo
label on strawberries or grapes for
example it's just a marketing ploy so my
professional opinion on this super hot
topic is that there are a hundred other
attributes i would judge a food on
before concerning myself with gmos i
might limit a lot of ultra processed
foods that are made with gmos not
because i'm specifically scared of the
gmos but because their overall nutrition
content might not be as great as an
unprocessed food and while i pretty much
always am saying the dose makes the
poison i actually don't think we even
have any quality evidence that gmos
specifically are poisonous at all
[Music]
at least not in contrast with their
non-gmo counterparts but that brings me
to a specific and very common gmo canola
oil now canola oil is kind of a triple
threat to a lot of wellness influencers
because a it's a gmo b
it contains inflammatory fats and c
it's highly refined let's break these
down
one by one so canola is one of the most
widely used plant oils in the food
industry it's also one of the major gmo
crops grown and sold in north america
the science against which we've already
debunked that puts concern one of three
to bed the second strike against canola
oil is its fatty acid composition
wellness influencers love to call out
canola as an inflammatory oil since it's
made up of about 20 linoleic acid which
is a common omega-6 fat now it's long
been speculated that the typical western
diet which is very high in omega-6s and
very low in omega-3 fats increases
inflammation which leads to chronic
disease this has ultimately led to the
demonization of refined vegetable oils
like canola which i discussed in a
little bit more detail in my video right
here but in short while some studies
have pointed to the potential
inflammatory properties of a diet rich
in omega-6 fats the larger body of high
quality evidence suggests that omega-6
fats themselves don't actually have a
significant effect on inflammation in
fact a 2012 systematic review assessed
the effects of omega-6 linoleic acid on
inflammatory markers like c-reactive
protein cytokines and tumor necrosis
factor and found no strong link to
suggest that it increased inflammation
there is even some research suggesting
that omega-6 fats may even be associated
with a reduced risk of cardiovascular
events plot twist i know ultimately we
may see variation in the literature as
research suggests different people's
genetics age sex body composition blood
lipid levels and gut microbiome can all
impact their response to different fatty
acids the reality is that a lot of
highly refined nutrient poor foods are
rich in omega-6 fats because they may be
deep fried in oils that happen to be
high in omega-6 fats but i would argue
that a diet rich in refined and
deep-fried carbs isn't going to be
nutritionally ideal even if said frying
were to be done in like olive or coconut
oil but that brings me to canola's third
concern how it's processed and refined
anytime an oil is refined all this
basically means is that it's processed
to one withstand high heat two make it
more stable to prolong shelf life and
three
be more uniform in taste smell and
appearance but there also exists a lot
of concern and controversy around the
process of bleaching and deodorizing
during the refining process of canola
which i get because when i think of the
word bleach i automatically think about
the liquid bleach that we clean with
which as we know is highly toxic when
consumed don't you put it in your mouth
don't you put it in your mouth don't you
stuff it in your face but it's actually
just a general term and usually canola
is bleached using different types of
clays often naturally occurring ones to
remove any contaminants ditto for
deodorization which uses hot steam to
remove oxidation products now one of the
other scary words associated with canola
is hexane
and that's basically what they use as a
solvent to remove the oils from the seed
but wellness influencers love to point
out that hexane is also used in things
like chemical cleaners and car fuel what
they don't tell you is that hexane has a
very very low toxicity level and there
is no evidence to substantiate any risks
of ingesting these trace amounts not to
mention it's estimated that there's only
0.8 milligrams of residual hexane per
kilogram of oil and that the ingestion
of hexane from all food sources makes up
less than two percent of the daily
intake from all sources most of which we
get from gasoline fumes but let's go
back to processing for a sec now heating
and processing oils like canola
ultimately strips away some of the
nutritional value of the oil and can
result in the formation of harmful trans
fats and given what we know about trans
fats and their health risks this is not
ideal
no
however the amount of trans fats in
canola oil specifically is one highly
variable and two comparable to other
oils for example one study comparing the
trans fat content of multiple oils found
that on average the commercial canola
oil can contain anywhere from 1.9
to 3.6 trans fats whereas walnut oil
contains anywhere from two to three
point nine percent but for some reason
we don't see walnut oil getting the same
negative pr as canola oil regardless
like all things related to nutrition
context is important here and the amount
of trans fat that you would reasonably
consume from canola oil or any other oil
is unlikely to cause serious harm in the
context of a balanced diet so to put it
in perspective the who recommends
limiting trans fat intake to less than
2.2 grams a day for the average 2000
calorie diet with that in mind one
tablespoon of canola oil provides
roughly .2 grams of trans fat and you
can divide that by four if you're using
that oil to cook a meal for a family of
four and if you are still concerned
about the impact of the refining process
on nutritional content and fat
composition the good news is that you
can absolutely purchase canola oil that
is minimally processed or unrefined by
looking for the label cold pressed or
expeller pressed these oils are
definitely less processed but the
trade-off is that they're less stable
have a shorter shelf life and are more
expensive so that's why we really don't
see them used in large scale food
processing very much so what is my
overall take on canola oil well
ultimately in my eyes
canola actually has a generally very
healthy fatty acid composition it may be
20 omega-6 but it's actually 60 percent
monounsaturated fats and 10
omega-3 fats meaning it has the ideal
two-to-one ratio of omega-6 to omega-3s
that we know is associated with better
health i think wellness culture has used
it as a scapegoat unnecessarily simply
because it's consumed in excess via
ultra processed foods and it's the
excess consumption of ultra processed
foods that's the much bigger fish to fry
so i say if you're getting the majority
of your fats from whole food sources in
your day and then cooking your
vegetables or your fish in regular
canola oil or enjoying the occasional
refined convenience food made with
canola oil folks it's all gonna net out
as a generally very healthy diet but if
we're eating the majority of our
calories in ultra-processed convenience
food that happens to be prepared with
canola oil well i would say that that is
the pattern that we would probably want
to try to shift and if you're still
concerned because you're using your
cooking oil as your primary source of
fat then choosing a cold pressed oil may
be a better nutrition bang for your buck
so on that note i hope this information
helped to lift some food fear and make
you a more informed and critical
consumer and like i've said before the
focus should be on overall dietary
pattern not on specific nutrients or
ingredients in any given food so if you
like this video be sure to give it the
thumbs up leave me a comment below on
which food additives you want to see me
discuss next a big thank you again to
betterhelp for sponsoring this video
subscribe to this channel and i will see
you next time on abby's kitchen bye
[Music]